HAPPY NEW YEAR.
I NEED TO TURN NOW TO
NEW YORK CITY WHERE CRIME IS ON
THE RISE.
ATTACKS ON POLICE OFFICERS ARE
BECOMING MORE AND MORE PREVALENT
AND A STRING OF ANTI-SEMITIC
ATTACKS LEAVES THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY ON EDGE.
THIS WEEKEND, FIVE WERE STABBED
DURING A HANUKKAH CELEBRATION AT
A RABBIS HOME IN NEW YORK STATE.
NEAR A CITY MAYOR de BLASIO
SPOKE OUT TO GIVE HIS
CONDOLENCES BUT HE ALSO PLACED
THE BLAME SQUARELY ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> AN ATMOSPHERE OF HATE HAS
BEEN DEVELOPING IN THIS COUNTRY
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
A LOT IS EMANATING FROM
WASHINGTON AND IS HAVING AN
EFFECT ON ALL OF US.
>> YOU ARE BLAMING THE
PRESIDENT?
>> NOT JUST THE PRESIDENT.
WE NEED A DIFFERENT TONE
STARTING IN WASHINGTON.
>> Jason: AY-YAI-YAI.
JOB EARLY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION WHEN YOU
HEAR THE MAYOR THAT YOU WORK
WITH THEIR REALIZE YOU'RE IN THE
OTHER PARTY, YOU'RE IN THE
MINORITY BUT WHAT'S YOUR
REACTION?
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED.
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME
MAYOR de BLASIO HAS PROVEN HOW
BURIED HIS HEAD IS IN THE SAND
ON ANTI-SEMITISM HERE
NEW YORK CITY.
SIX MONTHS AGO THERE WAS ANOTHER
SPIKE IN ANTI-SEMITIC CRIMES IN
BROOKLYN AND HE DECLARED TO THE
MEDIA THAT ANTI-SEMITISM IS A
RIGHT-WING MOVEMENT.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE TO EXPLAIN
TO YOUR VIEWERS THAT CENTRAL
BROOKLYN ISN'T EXACTLY A HOTBED
OF REPUBLICAN ACTIVITY.
THESE WEREN'T MAGA HAD PEOPLE
DOING THE CRIMES.
HE MISLED PEOPLE ABOUT THE CAUSE
OF ANTI-SEMITISM, LIKE HE IS
MISLEADING PEOPLE ABOUT THE
CAUSES TODAY.
>> Jason: THE PRIORITIES OF
THIS MAYOR, WHAT NEWARK CITY IS
DOING.
WALK US THROUGH.
YOU HAVE THINGS LIKE BAIL REFORM
AND RELEASING PRISONERS, GIVING
OUT GIFT CARDS.
THINGS ARE FOREIGN TO THE REST
OF US THAT LIVE IN THE REAL
WORLD.
>> IT MAKES US QUESTION OUR
PRIORITIES.
WE HAVE BAIL REFORM WHICH
ADVOCATES TELL US IT'S ABOUT
MARIJUANA AND LOW-LEVEL CRIMES.
THIS WEEKEND, WE SAW A VIOLENT
ATTACK ON A POLICE OFFICER ON
CAMERA FOR EVERYONE TO SEE.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN LOCK HIM UP AND
THROW AWAY THE KEY.
YET THIS PERP WAS RELEASED BACK
ONTO THE STREET BEFORE THE COP
WAS OFF HIS TOUR.
THAT PERP WAS BACK ON THE CORNER
BEFORE THIS COP WAS HOME ON THE
COUCH WITH HIS FAMILY.
THESE ARE THE PRIORITIES OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Jason: THIS IS VIDEO.
WE ARE LOOKING AT IT.
THIS PERSON GOES TO THE JAIL AND
IS BACK OUT BEFORE THIS GUY
SHIFT IS EVEN DONE.
>> BAIL REFORM IS GOING INTO
FULL EFFECT IN 26 HOURS AND
NEW YORKERS SHOULD BE CONCERNED.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HATE
CRIMES.
THIS WEEK AND ALSO A WOMAN WAS
RELEASED FROM CUSTODY AFTER
ASSAULTING THREE JEWISH WOMEN
ONLY TO BE RELEASED IN THE NEXT
DAY, ASSAULT MORE JEWISH WOMEN.
THIS IS THE STATE OF PLAY IN
NEW YORK CITY AND IT SHOULD BE A
WARNING TO ALL THE VIEWERS
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT THIS IS
THE TYPE OF GOVERNMENT THEY WILL
GET IF YOU ELECT PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATS.
BE FOREWARNED FRANKLY.
>> Jason: THE CITY,
NEW YORK CITY, I TRAVEL THERE
PRETTY REGULARLY WITH FOX.
THAT CITY HAS TOTALLY CHANGED
FROM THE TIME WHERE IT WAS WITH
RUDY GIULIANI AND THE POLICE
COMMISSIONER CHARACTER TO WHAT
BILL de BLASIO IS DOING THERE
AND THERE ARE PEOPLE FLEEING AT
EVERY MOMENT.
THEN NUMBERS OF PEOPLE FLOWING
OUT OF NEW YORK GOING TO PLACE
LIKE FLORIDA, SOUTH CAROLINA,
AND OTHER BEAUTIFUL PLACES.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE STATE OF
NEW YORK.
>> THERE WAS A REPORT OUT TODAY
WE WON THE PRICE.
WE LOST 180,000 RESIDENTS TO
OTHER STATES, THE BEST DATE FOR
THAT THIS YEAR.
ALSO THE BEST DATE FOR THAT THIS
DECADE.
IT'S PALPABLE.
MAYOR de BLASIO IS A FAILED
MARRIAGE YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
MY WORD FOR IT.
WHEN HE RAN FOR PRESIDENT, NOT
ONE AMERICAN IN 100 ANSWERED AND
PAUL SAYING THE JOB HE'S DOING,
WE WANT THAT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
HE SHOULD TAKE IT AS A GRAIN OF
SALT, PERHAPS RECALIBRATE AND
READJUST THE THINGS HE DOES.
HOPEFULLY RECALIBRATE THE CITY
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
>> Jason: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE
WHAT YOU'RE GOING THROUGH.
THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE
IN NEW YORK CITY BUT THE
PRIORITY, TELL ME VERY
SPECIFICALLY WHAT SHOULD BE DONE
TO PROTECT THE JEWISH COMMUNITY?
THERE'S BEEN A HUGE RASH DURING
HANUKKAH OF ATTACKS.
>> MY COLLEAGUES, JEWISH
DEMOCRATS BY THE WAY, VERY BRAVE
ONES, HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR MORE
POLICE, MORE SECURITY CAMERAS,
MORE SECURITY GUARDS IN HOUSES
OF WORSHIP ALL ACROSS THE CITY
FOR MONTHS.
THIS RISE IS NOT NEW.
WE HAVE A RECENT RISE IN
DECEMBER BUT THIS HAS BEEN A
YEAR-LONG THING.
64% RISE IN ANTI-SEMITIC HATE
CRIMES AND FINALLY NOW AFTER ALL
THIS TIME, NOW WE ARE GOING TO
IMPLEMENT MORE POLICE OFFICERS.
THE MAYOR HAD A HATE CRIME
TASK FORCE FORMED IN SEPTEMBER
AND HE BASICALLY HIRED HALF THE
POSITIONS BECAUSE IT WASN'T A
PRIORITY.
IT'S JUST NOT A PRIORITY, JASON.
THAT HAS TO CHANGE.
>> Jason: IT JUST HAVE TO
CHANGE.
JOB EARLY, I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
COMING ON TO EXPLAIN IT.
HAVE A HAPPY AND SAFE NEW YEAR.
>> PEOPLE SHOULD STILL COME TO
TIMES SQUARE!
IT'S STILL A SAFE CITY.
THEY SHOULD STILL COME.
>> Jason: THE WAY THE
NEW YORK CITY POLICE DEPARTMENT